oh good morning gamers come here don't
move don't move don't move do not jump
at me you do not jump back to me I will
you that's right we're back with this
view now that's right we're back with
this view you guys complain enough I
listen that's how this works
can you what's happening oh damn damn
girl damn girl dude I bet you could
download so huh hey baby hey baby how
are you hey Queen Queen Queen yeah girl
I love you come on give me another one
give me another one you [ __ ]
catch take it another one oh come on hey
[ __ ] out another one hey here you go I'm
getting rid of all of them I don't care
yes yeah
that's a good one
dumb body once told me the world it's
gonna tickly come on come on baby that's
right that's right
shame shame on you you better not do
this for any other guy that comes in all
right
if jacksepticeye comes in and ask what
do you do you say no you're my girl no
one else ain't no by the years hey I'm
sorry
all right let's keep going I'm ready to
go down yeah ready to go down and see
what's happening get them get Adam out
so people have been commenting that I
haven't been putting it in my backpack
like it's a backpack but the
instructions said clearly that I put it
behind my head so I think I was right
where was I my god there's still there's
still really oh my god so many dude they
must be keep spawning
all right we go up that's right we go up
that's how you open doors in Sweetland
oh you got taken put my gosh Oh toot
stones in one Rock why did I do that why
did I do that I'm an idiot
oh nasty that wasn't hasty okay so where
do I go they must be here oh I see I see
I've done this before you just got to be
really careful ah yes of course
I we I don't have to do that but I like
doing it do you understand why it's a
grenade there hey hey don't don't do it
that's precious to me are you gonna blow
is he gonna blow no dammit I was worried
he was gonna blow there you go now you
can block Jesus that was faster than I
thought
all right
I'm not sure entirely like where I'm
supposed to go that's right I got P P
Hill in here gamers oh so that's why we
have to follow this so I found the
solution before I found the error that's
how you know you're a real gamer that's
how you know it's really done that's how
you know you do it I have a feeling I
have to go down to them this is my game
or intuition speaking Arabic I've
returned for the 500th time another one
another one that's flesh
don't follow me I'm Swedish you can't
follow haha dumb yo sit down oh god what
happened to your face dude be quiet
what is this okay I'll grab that later I
don't need it now
[Music]
can you be quiet can you be quiet
can you be quiet no one likes you
because you're hairy and I'm not gonna
say the other thing oh cool yeah that's
what I wanted to do nailed it
are you serious oh my god is this gun oh
my god yes so I put that in the pp
there's a shoot now this is shoot let's
try hey sit still sister
that dead dead dead dead dead dead
then that dead dead dead - dead dead
alright it works okay
all right stop crying what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
can you be quiet be quiet in there Wow
oh this is a tricky one guys I'm gonna
get to you don't worry don't panic it oh
oh there's two of them now yeah you see
how fast I saw that high five nice all
right come back come back I like it come
up to me
[Music]
sit down sit down
that's what I'm talking about no one
messes with me
nobody mine mine mine
dude I'm good at this game now look how
fast I do this this would take me years
before all right what do I need I need
something here probably okay
oh yeah oh yeah I've done a couple leads
before this is a little spooky don't be
scared Alex only scared people get
scared then damn that's sexy
look at that god damn girl Oh
Oh someone the air hey more stuff I mean
they're very generous in this place
how's my health do kids drugs
I mean don't oh my god there's so many
well that's it that's all I do that's so
cool if only I had a grenade catch it
catch it come to me dumb body
so dumb that they're a freakin dummy
you're also freaking them in and you're
so stinky stinky stupid it's gotta make
sure bring it flip tipping tipping
what's happening here what am i touching
what the hell am i touching sit that
flippin sit oh I like that
all right let me just climb yeah that's
how you climb ladders in Sweden they
teaches that in ladder climbing school
sit there flipping and yeah don't I
tried to warn him I need to relearn I
think not thought I think not I think I
said no in front of my girl she butts me
but how are you baby are you doing girl
you alright yeah another one come on I
know you have more I know you had more
another one yeah [ __ ] who wants son huh
are you watching nice are you watching
this sophisticated swishing down
well I don't think so
I think the answer is no yes sir all
right where was the force field it was
one look flora but listen I but I am on
the top floor nothing
oh I get it
Jesus what's wrong with you
night in if you guys could stop back to
knock it off that'd be great
all right here we go yeah yeah oh this
is fun I like what is happening I like
this
who would have thought climbing ladders
were so fun when you don't weigh
anything fat people be like bra
dude that's a lot of them I don't make
sense why they gave me so many goddamn
ammo now no it's okay I don't need
health okay how about this
rock paper scissor okay rock paper
scissor okay you won that one rock paper
scissor I won't press oh oh I thought I
pressed oh dude this is a big mistake on
my part I totally messed that one up you
would understand if it was me ah yeah
yeah what sir
bomb give me ball whoa that's a thick
one damn that stick oh my god
that's awesome dan that's a lot of
puzzles here to it at the same time you
can't do that okay No
[Music]
that it caused this a monster okay thank
you
dude we got a lot I'm oh we got a big
battle coming up you know it
[Music]
let's make sure we reload everything
hmm hi I'm ready anything you got I'm
ready I'm not scared at all what is this
I need battery I know how to find this
what am i touching what am i touching
where am i oh my god I'm so out of frame
dude shut up barrels shut up oh my god
more are you serious
alright speed run speed run speed run
speed run yeah give me more give me more
give it to me one mag what are you poor
what do you live poor town we're poor
people are in towns together all right
what are we looking at what I'm looking
at okay so clearly huh what dude is
there something behind you guys cuz I
can't quite a show quite a show this
means do not throw got it
hey hey seven oh god I hate them they
stink okay
stinky the flap down alright ready for
spider-man jump
what's good ah what do you want boy how
do you work boy
who said that are you here I'm afraid of
nothing nothing what's good
yeah yeah come on come on
is that all you got oh it's the head
yeah shotgun shotgun
you can't run but you can't hide
it's good it's good yeah oh look at this
yeah the register
very good I had one shot left but I need
to make sure I'm good
excuse me excuse me I'm talking to you
I know my [ __ ] clothes went out look
where is it where's his weak spot right
you couldn't you were acting that's
right
you can't hide from Swedish [ __ ]
[Applause]
neither Hey look at this it's not a
party catch body wants to me no well is
gonna nice dude it's it's it's sounding
like strangling of a totes again I don't
know why I keep hearing it it's just a
repeating sound I don't like it either
oh it's you you are the toad
do I do anything with this okay I think
that was good that was good
all right so we follow the other wire
yes yes no one's talking catch I'm not
addicted all right there are just
minerals I swear
minerals I swear I saw something
directing for me yes that's what I'm
talking about
yeah that's what I'm talking about
we did it oh no what with that sound
that sounded not that sounded good
bish I know to count oh really you think
I have no memory because you're
absolutely right okay so I got you I got
you let's check in here hey we came back
to where we were before but where I need
another battery that means we're missing
something
battery dude that's Earth doesn't work
okay
could it be in here ah could it be in
here it's good it'd be in here yeah yeah
I get me
I made it in ah it didn't even hurt yeah
[ __ ] headphones whoever designed
headphones I know they're my own
headphones okay guys I know there are my
own headphones and I know they're
wireless okay but the [ __ ] things
just annoys me you know all the
celebrities singing imagine there's no
heaven imagine there's no headphones
think about that music transmitted into
our ears maybe there's one of these
things where I can grab it and then just
run alright that doesn't work well let's
check upstairs if I miss something
obvious [ __ ] barrister
so maybe this opens oh my got it okay
big brain big brain system main yeah you
can open now is that the blue one and I
need the red one I need the blue one
whoa what can I see you did I walk all
the way around
yes I did because big brain all right
what's good girl
what's good damn these are some
thick-ass boxes dude
nice place mother blahblah
all right are you ready
I haven't been there in years bad smell
remind me something madam your death my
ex-wife okay we made it all right I'm
down had that but that's fine
open are you there are you nearby oh you
must be so scared don't worry
felix is here felix gonna take care of
you
oh god three of them yeah yeah easy as a
mashed potatoes oh you must be so scared
oh my god hey don't cry don't cry don't
cry
hey Australia I'm here I'm here
I'm your dad that's right I'm your new
dad I'm not gonna put you in there don't
worry don't worry I'm not gonna do it
that's what messed up people do I bet a
ton of other people that play this game
just want to use you for hell but you're
so beautiful
no are you alive so sorry my finger
slipped
are you okay
oh my god stop crying subcribe stop
crying alright you go in then I'm not
gonna touch it though
you stay there it's just so you stay
there alright I'll snap some mother
flipping cables my dude
that's large
[Music]
I like it oh it's over here
I think it's something
okay so how do I keep it open though
[Music]
that's fine it's fun these things
happens all the time there used to it
[Music]
I'm gonna be fast here just for the
sticker I did I did that you ain't got
no power what motherf lapa hey so go out
there so go on it so go there what do
you say go inside and deactivate damn
[Music]
not too close how long you're free now
it's your free man your friend sent me
what are you doing - you hear what they
do
why would they bring the damn that ass
why is he going dude be careful all
right do you want some underpants or
something
imagine when when aliens comes to earth
and we just depicts them as naked and
maybe like bruh how uncivilized do you
think we are you know what I mean
what do you think I can't really I can't
really we have to stop them from killing
your friends the vortigaunt will expect
ourselves and exact our own what I can't
get into the vault
if the substations I still online do not
worry Alex okay I like that
[Music]
thanks thanks thank you mrs. Gaiman it
was quiet
of course we made it a lot of stuff Hey
look at that so Jay oh yeah you put
these here so Jen there's nice corbera
so where do I go now huh No
oh no my mom warned me of this
completely pathetic you found for the
oldest trick in the book mother [ __ ]
[ __ ]
don't hurt
I'm out of ammo
they keep falling for it they keep
falling for it some bum anyone else
wants them what they do know anything
stop it
touch it you dumbass catch it yeah yeah
yeah to throw to draw anyone else wants
some blowing up a teat someone wants
some Slurpee therapy huh
you want some slap me [ __ ] derpy ah
hey what's in there what's in there love
[ __ ] my child you have come back I love
you I [ __ ] love you I'll always love
you don't worry don't worry
I keep you safe yes I found all your all
your relatives all your siblings yeah
they're all safe if you just come with
me if you just come with me and shampoo
where you go there we go ah
they were just hold up one second bro oh
this is enough good sage and finally
Jesus Christ in his power doesn't it
uh-huh okay coming from coming from
coming from oh it's doing all council
weird [ __ ] whoa whoa what I only thought
was supposed to happen it's right augh
out dude this one is tricky there we go
finally I can upgrade there it's been
years
oh my god more are you serious oh my god
the continues how disease work refracts
got it I see it there we go just open
just open please please I did not need
three puzzles for that okay so what if
we put this in laser sign Oh
notice I how I had 69 restin by the way
yeah give me that gimme gimme yeah yeah
oh oh it's smoking dude Eknath stop it
in Soviet Russia is our gun do I need
anything for this now
shotgun might be good what a shotgun D
autoloader double shot mmm at 34 laser
please okay I hope I made the right
choices here where are my children
there they are oh my god it fits in
there the Solaris okay cold we're done
here it's not right [ __ ]
I'll keep you there right don't worry
you're safe you're safe with me dude we
got a frickin laser sight dude oh my god
this makes the game so much easier
I can aim that's my whatsapp who keeps
writing me stop it whoever it is
stopping dan that looks cool
all its some more fighting isn't it go
bleach you got this I believe in you
bleach would never fail me oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] dammit ha ha am I right bleach [ __ ]
yeah that's right it's fine let's check
in the fridge bleach don't [ __ ] swear
you little [ __ ]
alright I'm not gonna raise some sort of
swearing son of a running a bit low on
ammo but that's fine
shut up
all right you check if it's safe I'll
come back here for you later all right
we got lazy sighs we got laces hats we
got late sweets I got late oh that's a
trap that's a trap oh yes por favor
finally yeah
I promised him I promised him I wouldn't
hurt him
and if I never breaks promise brood upon
never breaks up promise um oh yeah you
can try hide for me oh dude that finally
something soft oh I see you I see you
hello hello anybody home it's clear
Jake's us what did i do a hairbrush
check if it's safe
it's it safe that's my [ __ ] laser
sign bottom
stop that dumbass [ __ ] how are you in
this place this [ __ ] sucks dude say
my name [ __ ] say my [ __ ] name
what's cooking good-looking are you
kidding me
mother [ __ ]
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about you boys better
not sneak up on me now you can never be
too safe
damn that I asked girl you're making a
lot of noise trace what what do you have
on yeah yeah yeah what's this what's
this huh [ __ ] thought he had a chance
shot he thought he had a chance [ __ ]
sit the [ __ ] down sit the [ __ ] down go
back to chunk that came out racist I
mean he looks like a jungle monster
that's what I meant
aa jungle monster oh my god I'm gonna
get in trouble for everything
is there anything back here keep hearing
the beeping hey stop that Oh could it be
could we could we be talking Alex no
what's that spinning stopping can I turn
up the lights befriender cool oh how do
I deal with this can I jump over it
should I throw something in front of me
I don't really have anything Oh perfect
you're okay
here look at that this is a mother
flipping workout in
I heard something
yes calculator I found you it doesn't
even work
what does he make us huh
finally thank you I'm not the strayed
I'm not the thread enough son we are
getting there I don't like the sound of
the bugs dad you were like father to me
okay good honey
it's not good you may not get to work on
the data part what an app you're nasty
[ __ ]
you are nasty gas you're nasty
all right ready Superman jump really bad
I haven't heard that I haven't heard
that name in years
I haven't smash that subscribe down that
[ __ ] in years
what arms race okay
sounds like a nice time mutha [ __ ]
mutha [ __ ] you want some mother [ __ ]
another one I just had one all right
damn
yeah yeah all right I never use this I
better put something on it call I can't
do anything great Clyde Jake stop glad
we did then at least give me something
right it's not right bucking we're doing
a blind let's play now gamers
surprise
oh my god yeah I get it I'm supposed to
push these down right no I'm supposed to
use that I like that a little death all
right so this is a puzzle I believe I
can use my brain to solve these ba ba ba
ba ba hey bucket you made it back
bro you guys have beans
that's something so crazy so Creoles I
know I'm more cringe but dude I'm not a
writer at least I don't need a comic
relief in half life you know me am i
controlling this am I actually
controlling this
that's a bit high isn't it maybe I can
control it inside it there's definitely
something in here you think you can hide
from PewDiePie the master of Secrets huh
the master of secrets kill kill the
master of Secrets you can't have nothing
for me nothing nothing
was that it Oh enjoy
booty pop flavor ooh oh it rained
oh he wet what am I doing here what am I
doing here in life huh what's the point
of life gamers help me with this one I
love how they did their smog and the Sun
set sunrise what English [ __ ] now I have
to go back because I thought for sure I
had to go to the crane thing damn I'm so
tall dude
Oh mr. salt gamers mystery solved
[Music]
we're back we are back mother papa now
come on bear don't be shy come on you
know you love me
you know you love him you know you care
shop might be be nah be there
you want them to have to control that
later maybe well that remains to be seen
Steve Mason finally
Cerie viens service my favorite boxer
don't shoot
why do you look like general Kenobi
I mean I'm general Kenobi something you
want to go nice thing not it's time to
shine
what am I supposed to do
I don't like this why did he stop hello
hi it's safe
cool it's safe where did he go I'm
actually scared of this guy shut
[Music]
I'm innocent
okay okay look at this look at this
[ __ ] looked this looked hey you like
looking at hey I see you
you guys are nasty I don't like you very
much I shoot you I shoot you
I shoot you shoot you shoot you I shoot
to shoot the shooter yeah
tape My Love My Love Boat gang boot gang
is back fish I was so scared that I lost
you forever
but nothing can stop love but you
understand there's nothing we will
forever be net what it can't be - you're
faker I'll let you live only because you
look so goddamn beautiful what's
happened here huh we're here huh
is anyone gonna answer me what happened
here
you know I will do it but you next you
would like it
Nestle son of a [ __ ] would like it he
would like it oh don't think I don't see
you up there
that's three something here come on
seriously all of that four barrels put
some [ __ ] barrels Jesus one second
guys one second guys
yeah I go there go there huh big dumb
asses they don't see me anymore
[ __ ] that's how we do it in
Sweden hat
markiplier we're good yeah you're right
you are very important okay come on muck
play love you sit sit I see you I see
you up there my love
where'd he go
markup I know know where we go life's
not fair yes life is fair
markiplier he is my maken man say bye
Sam's hey hey we can be friends to be we
can be friends we can be friends I swear
in bed buggabugga good one Felix
that was a good markiplier impression
yeah that's how he talks I see you up
there mother ah okay so why we multiply
[Music]
lose focus loose fingers you hear that
pay attention I'm back where I started
I knew that shut up Michael playing I
know what I'm doing I know what I'm
doing I know what this is doing I know
what I'm doing
I know what where am I going huh Who am
I getting mein do I remember that maybe
yeah yeah that's it dude I can use -
markiplier to remove that yeah
markiplier you can't do this to me
you can't do this to me markiplier
markiplier stop it
I got it I got it I solved the puzzle I
saw the puzzle I need the barrel
I need a bow
today we work together today we complete
puzzles together
PewDiePie and Beryl collaboration in a
million years no one would have thought
of it but today it happened Oh surprise
yeah you okay that did you come from hey
you dropped something
oops never in a million years would they
think all right guys I know this is way
sir I'm open like watch me hit those
bottles and after a spin shot alright
because everyone keeps saying I'm bad at
aiming watch this
alright through my legs it falls off my
head I can't do it okay while frickin
alright I can't do it well frickin
whatever that's a guy thing alright yeah
this women before guys can't do two
things at once everyone knows this
cheeks us dance til you dead Oh
dance till your dad and aunt and hey hey
I see you this is the most badass way to
do it where it's bleach
why don't you where do I go now wait go
now let's get there let's get the bleach
son oh there I go there okay yeah my way
get out of my way get out of my way
don't talk to me don't touch me no
Orlick say your last prayer lock yeah
hello are you friendly I'd say yes
I say yes
I'm the guy with a hand yeah you look a
little different are you chubby
markiplier I like that I like a man with
a little meat on his bones you know I'm
saying more compliant oh damn it alright
I'll toss you up
[Laughter]
[Music]